[Music]
[Music]
are you okay do you need help
oh I'm good why cheat chip
oh yeah you guys cover that up on land
huh I'm the mermaid Oh former roommate
how do you guys even use these things oh
my god something back there oh that's
where my blowhole is so you're a mermaid
huh yeah you may have heard of my friend
Ariel those little my mate Jimmy honest
she's not so little but when we were
down there she kept telling me how like
amazing it is on land and I was like
whatever but then after the hundredth
time of getting a freaking straw stuck
up my nose I need to find myself a sea
witch and have her turn me into a unit
so here I am
do you know where the princess art print
and you wanna have those here in Florida
one they come
graboid do killers alligators so where
are they come with me
the only princess I know of arm from
here for all in England
you gotta get on a plane to see them buy
a ticket how money
how work no no I don't work I'm a
princess
want some friends up so thank you only
fresh seaweed what you've got in your
nose what's in it that's what we drink
mouth I don't know what I was thinking
and coming here I'm gonna go back to the
Witch and tell her to change me back
into a mermaid now so thank you for your
time won't we
wait he beat me and swimmer me too
now hey I have an excellent wingman I
can help you find a prince no okay
Oh fYI it's a really far way down to the
sea wish and I can't guarantee your
lungs won't explode honestly it's better
than going on another Saturday